we are now going to introduce ourselves
to the idea of utility in economics now
in everyday language if someone says
what's the utility of that they're
usually saying what's the usefulness of
doing that and utility in economics
takes that view of utility and extends
that a little bit you could view utility
and economics as a measure of usefulness
usefulness
worth
value
some economist will even say it's a
measure of happiness because things that
might not have a practical use can still
have utility to them in economics
because they're giving you some
satisfaction or some happiness so i'll
even write that over here
and as we'll see it
is something that economists try to
measure or try to quantify and they do
it with just utility units so let's see
a tangible example of that
so let's say you wanted to think about
your utility from scoops of ice cream so
if we say let's make a call let's make a
table here so number of scoops
that'll be in my left column and on my
right column let's think about total
total
utility
and i will do it in utils you could view
that as your unit of utility
and let me put my columns in here
so
there we go
and so let's say if i have zero scoops
of ice cream well you might guess what
my utility is going to be it is going to
be zero
now what if i have one scoop of ice
cream
well let's just say that that is 80
utility units and i know what you're
thinking so where did you come up with
80 utility units and this is really just
an arbitrary number that i'm throwing
down here what's more important is what
this is relative to my utility for other
things so for example using this scale
if i said
two scoops of ice cream my total utility
is 140
80 and 140 aren't what matter what
matters is the ratio between the two so
if i said my utility for one scoop of
ice cream was 800 then if this ratio is
true then for two scoops of ice cream my
total utility would be 1400 it could be
8 million and 14 million what matters is
the relative utility i just happened to
anchor on one scoop gives me eight units
total utility units but let's keep going
if we go with this scale then three
scoops of ice cream let's say that this
gives me 180 units of utility and i know
what you're saying well even if you get
the ratio right how do you even know
that this is the right ratio well
economists will debate how to measure
this but there might be ways that you
could measure it maybe with dollars with
what people are willing to pay and then
you can get the ratios you could survey
people you could say on a scale of ten
one to ten how happy will it make you if
you got one scoop of ice cream what if
you got two scoops of ice cream what if
you got three and then you would want to
get these ratios right but of course it
is an inexact science but people are
trying to quantify this and let's just
go to four
four scoops of ice cream would give you
a total utility let's say we knew it
would give you a total utility of
170.
now something interesting is happening
as you got more scoops of ice cream from
zero to one to from one to two from two
to three it looks like you are getting
more utility but then all of a sudden
when you have four scoops of ice cream
your total utility goes down a little
bit
maybe it's because people can't eat four
scoops of ice cream and they say what do
i do with that and they just have
they're left with a bowl of melted ice
cream and so it doesn't give them as
much utility it makes them feel bad
somehow as having three bowls of ice
cream or three scoops of ice cream
another thing to think about is how much
does the total utility increase every
time you get an incremental unit of that
thing and we'll talk about it in more
depth in future videos but that general
idea of how much more utility you get
for that incremental unit and it cut in
economics when we're talking about what
happens on the increment we use the word
marginal a lot
marginal
utility
utility sometimes abbreviated mu
and this would still be in utility units
and so we could start with that first
going from zero to one i'll start with
that first scoop of ice cream what's the
marginal utility well it gave you an
incremental 80 units of utility so the
marginal utility is 80. now what about
that second scoop of ice cream well we
know when you had one you had 80 total
utility units and now when you have two
you have 140 so that incremental second
scoop gave you to go from 80 to 140 it
gave you 60 extra units of utility
so notice you were really you really
increased your happiness or you got a
lot of value out of that first group and
you still got value out of that second
scoop but it's a little bit less because
you're not maybe just as hungry you're
getting a little bit tired of the ice
cream and then that continues to happen
on that third scoop to go from 140 to
180 that third scoop gave you 40 units
of utility
and then as we talked about when you add
on that fourth scoop it didn't even add
to your total utility it took away from
your total utility so it actually had a
negative marginal utility it is negative
10. that fourth scoop actually took away
from your happiness so i will leave you
there you have this idea of utility
total utility and we also looked at
marginal utility and you see in this
example and this is typical that
marginal utility typically decreases as
you get more and more units of that
thing
and in future videos we're going to use
this framework of utility total utility
marginal utility to think about how
folks might make rational decisions to
optimize their total utility